the average person burns a couple
thousand calories a day yeah so these
nine thousand nine thousand calories
yeah it's a nine thousand we have a VAT
Satori mixer vegetables grilled in the
oven then there is a McGee sausages from
the local butter grilled salmon with
basil and tarragon then we have a
capella and a coleslaw then there's some
bread and of course always pass the the
best is on its way that's a lot of food
for not so big cyclists yeah
a normal guy for dinner would eat around
450 500 grams of food these guys maybe
maybe a kilo so they're little but they
were in a shipping they eat a lot of
food a lot of pasta but also we try to
get them to eat a lot of vegetables as
well the pastas yes and then the dough
go through all that pasta yes what is it
about this food that's different than
the way I would serve it up well we
don't deep-fry stuff we don't do like
fat food so everything is organic and
everything is like the best vegetables
you can get fresh stuff that's the most
important part and if you can get them
to eat a lot of vegetables it's good you
know serving wine with dinner if they
win a glass once in a while